اعلن رئيسه اركان الجيش الاوكراني عن
محادثات مزمع عقدها في السعوديه وقال ان
المحادثات ستكون ضمن منتدى للدول الملتزمه
بالحقوق الدوليه وقوانين الامم المتحده
المسؤول الاوكراني اكد ان روسيا لن تحضر
هذه المحادثه
وكان المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيومارر قد قال ان بلاده ترحب
بمؤتمر السلام الذي تعتزم السعوديه عقده
بشان اوكرانيا من الاكد خلال مؤتمر صحفيين
نواشنطن ستشارك فيه مشيرا الى ان اي حل
دبلوماسي مامول لوضع نهايه حرب لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا يجب ان تقوده على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
بالطبع ندعم قمه السلام بشان اوكرانيا
التي ستستضيفها السعوديه وكما نقول منذ
مده عندما يتعلق الامر باي حل دبلوماسي
محتمل لهذه الحرب فانه من المهم ان تكون
القياده لاوكرانيا في هذه المساله ويسعدنا
ان الدول التي لم تسمع بعد من اوكرانيا
ستكون هناك وتتحدث مباشره معها وفيما يخص
الدول التي ستدعى لهذه القمه فهذا الامر
يتعلق بالسعوديه واوكرانيا واوكدوا ان
هناك مسؤولين من الحكومه الامريكيه
سيحضرونها لكن لم يتم بعد اعلان من
سيكونون ونتوقع ان يتم ذلك خلال الاسبوع